from the biggest issues of the day to
the deepest issues of soul wonder
insight ideas it's time for Ted
we truly are living in an extraordinary
time space itself is stretching it's
expanding we cannot vote fear of failure
and make amazing new fruits we are a
brilliant and creative species this
could be our finest hour
as a kid I used to lie up in the pit the
stars and just wonder about why things
are the way they are and Ted's an
attempt to answer that question why do
we humans find ourselves in a universe
with a particular amount of dark energy
we've measured instead of any of the
other possibilities that are out there
what I want to show you next it's a
music video 9 robots play six different
instruments when you're in the presence
of a great speaker you're almost
hypnotized by levels they just bring you
along on their journey we need to think
big we need to invent our way out
working together it just kind of feeds
into the idea that I've always smell
you come to Ted and in your brain just
melts with the activity I went to the
Psychopaths tossing calls and I am now a
certified psychopath spotter we're
talking a 900-page book in which a hoard
of tiny people emerge from the mouth of
a sleeping girl and cause a German
Shepherd to Explo
so much of Ted is what people can see an
experience and learn that's not
available anywhere else we're inviting
people to turn their genes into their
own unique music track it is a form of
visual note-taking sort of capturing the
essence of the different speakers and
what they're saying of the multi-verse I
just love how spontaneous it is never
know what's gonna come next
he's full full of us full of our mom's
not about being scarce it's about
accessibility taking that which was
scarce and making it abundant you know
what the big secret about Ted is very
few people here are afraid to fail and
that's what this conference to me is
about it's about solving the problems of
the world and using really creative
solutions to do so the conversations
that I've had
the ways that I've been pushed and
challenged I'm definitely thinking more
globally than I was before all of our
survival is tied to the survival of
everyone
we cannot be full evolved human beings
until we care about humanity it's all
about you let's journey together let's
journey together this amazing
mind-blowing encouraging hopeful deeply
philosophical incredibly fun inspiring
epic incredible